peter du bist uns zugeschaltet aus dem
krankenhaus in berlin und jetzt hast du
uns auch peter erzählt uns erstmal wie
geht es dir mit corona was ist passiert
und wie ist der stand ja also haben wir
somit geht es deutlich besser als in den
anderen corinna patienten geht aber
berauschend ist das dann ja auch nicht
ich habe bewegungsradius von etwa zwei
metern den ich ja machen können
ich kann wenn man gefühlt sagt also man
hat das ist im volumen dann kann ich von
meinem lungenvolumen platz zwei
zentimeter an kanzler ist an arten
danach ist einfach feier hand kann man
nicht ansteigen kann nämlich auch wegen
haben tauben luft
die physiotherapie damit ich die atmen
kann
und also ist relativ schwierig ich hatte
eine woche lang schieber einmal zwischen
39 45 wurde sonstige symptome es war
weiter nichts hat er dann zum glück ein
team von ärzten wieder geguckt haben so
ein bisschen sagte aus mäßig was mit mir
los sei und dass man relativ schnell
darauf gestoßen dass obwohl ich negative
pcr test hatte obwohl schnelltest
negativ waren nicht doch krone habe dass
man da also überhaupt nicht sicher sagen
kann
einfach mal durch getestet worden ist in
den bergen zweimal
gcr getestet wurden beides mal negativ
weiter in deutschland nochmal negativen
plätzen die hatte trotzdem corona und
zum glück haben die ärzte richtig
reagiert und haben dann nach einer woche
wieder einzusetzen dann als sich das
geändert hat das ist auch logisch
mädchen gefordert
in einem krankenhaus in berlin sandte
losgeschickt
und da hat man doch mit der therapie an
ich habe also eine lungenentzündung wird
dazu aber aber sowas ist stabil das ist
auszuhalten
wird er jetzt gerade gesagt wo das
englische getestet und es wurde am
anfang nicht erkannt jetzt mittlerweile
bis zum krankenhaus heute sprechen wir
über die nächsten corona gipfel vor
allem über die lockerungen wie viele
menschen sich jetzt erhoffen was denkst
du jetzt über öffnungen wo du selber am
eigenen leib leider dass gerade erklärt
erfahren musste wie schwer ein crooner
dann doch treffen kann
na ja also ich würd es nicht aber im
eigentlichen machen ich würde einen dem
fest machen was mir erst eine ärztin
sitzen zwei wochen also bin dein woche
mann gesucht hat und jetzt in der
zweiten woche gewann bescheid weiß dass
man das erste die einzige gesagt haben
die krankenhäuser sind nicht die zahlen
gehen nicht runter wir haben etwas mit
der todeszahlen das liegt im
wesentlichen sagen wer die als zu daran
also jetzt die alten gut geschützt sind
die halten das sind die leute die
schneller sterben innerhalb von zehn
tagen sterben jetzt kommt die baby
boomer dran geht städten die sich durch
die mutanten stecken sich mehr leute an
darunter sind die baby boomer also die
leute 65 plus
sterben nicht so gut nicht so schnell da
gibt es dann noch die ganzen
sterbezahlen aber von denen kommen jetzt
mehr in den kliniken halten die
verstopfte schon die normale station in
dem klinikum in den beständen pat fry es
sollte eine instanz und getränken
krankenhaus kommen dass die charité habe
kein bett mehr frei
da sterben jetzt die leute zwar nicht
aber das auch nur dass jetzt ein loch
ist die leute länger liegen dann später
starb aber die krankenhäuser laufen voll
und wenn man das nicht hinkriegt mit
einer vernünftigen von der guten test
starteten dabei mir selber geld gesehen
was eine schicht geben gehen kann also
auf den serbischen pixel hat das sagen
ich mal gebe ich in meinem leben nichts
mehr habe nicht in den serien angestellt
ich hätte auch nicht hören sollen als
sich das flugzeug rein bin und gesehen
habe die leute ihre waffen getragen
haben das liga war beim alb vollmitglied
die leute an die maske nirgendwo schläge
oder dusche gehabt
ich hatte eigentlich umtrieben müssen
draußen ich hatte mir schon viel ja ganz
nach hinten weg gesetzt wo kein
andererseits weil man dann sieht wie zb
in serbien die sich vermögen seien lügen
darf im wesentlichen aber wie da die
regeln gelernt hat die leute da ohne
masken in restaurants jetzt bei uns im
hotel war was er komplett selber
schlachten dogs in der rosenstadt
dorfkirchen nicht einer von ihnen proben
hatte auch irgendetwas ansatzweise
gesicht hängt man hat sich also auf dem
hotelzimmer zurück bin zurück und
flüchtet bringen wir jetzt in
deutschland auch mal was sagen die ärzte
ohne eine vernünftige test statt und
nicht zu jedem zweiten schnelltest auch
ein pc hat zugehört lassen momentan fast
eine million kapazität die pcr test in
deutschland ungenutzt weil wir auch
erreichen wollen apple stellte stellt
das sind aber nicht zu verletzen
jetzt nicht so zuverlässig mit in seinem
gegen sie sein müssen wenn man gast
lässt einmal an schulen ausprobiert und
mit kindertagesstätten das systematisch
dann in den griff kriegt darf man das
trink ich das sagen spezialisten vor ort
sagen die infektologe biologen und darf
man das nicht einfach das entdecken
machen man muss das so gut man muss das
getan und muss das beherrschen und dann
kann man locker aber ohne das am 1
wir sind einmal durchsetzen zu haben es
ist gefährlich hoch kriminell peter
bevor wir dich dann auch entlassen
sozusagen und die gute besserung
wünschen weil es alles sehr anstrengend
für dich dass das hören wir auch du hast
sozusagen über sein lungenvolumen
gesprochen was sagen die ärzte dir wie
lange muss du da bleiben wie lange wird
das dauern bis du dich wieder voll
erholt hast nimmst du bestimmte speziell
für corona verwandte medikamente jetzt
wie läuft so eine behandlung ab und dazu
wenn du heute natürlich nicht vom
kanzleramt stehst aber du standest auch
mit vielen ministerpräsidenten im
kontakt vielleicht sind jetzt einige
dabei die sagen man muss viel mehr
lockern stehst du da in sms-kontakt und
sagst den schaut mal was hier in den
krankenhäusern los ist also ich habe
mich tatsächlich ausbildung
ich kümmere mich jetzt tatsächlich
umgesetzt ich bin natürlich mit 23 bin
ich immer in kontakt bin auch kontakt
ministerpräsident jetzt nicht weiß was
in seinen krankenhäusern muss ist man
selber schuld ziemlich spät zu helfen
aber es ist natürlich zu auf der anderen
seite ja auch so beliebten druck und das
muss ja etwas dünn
das was nicht und was ist ja uns uns
drei die wir im monat mit seiner
berichten immer wieder fassungslos
zurück es ist doch dass wir immer noch
mit denselben sachen
dass sie immer noch darüber reden
plötzlich kam der herbst war nicht
vorbereitet dann kam dagegen kann man
war nicht verarbeitet jetzt geht man ins
frühjahr wenn man es wieder nicht
vorbereitet und man fragt sich
eigentlich was machen die länderchefs
eigentlich man kann ja immer auf den
grundstücken und dann muss man auch ganz
ganz ganz viel abladen
was für die meisten diskutiert werden
was an den schulen passiert was man im
einzelhandel passieren was ein test
strategien passiert sind die werden da
angekommen zuständig das zeigen uns dort
steht ihr wie tübingen oder wie rostock
die alternative wege gegangen zu binden
diese sehr erfolgreich gegangen oder
ganz gezogen jena als ich angefangen
habe mit einer maske nicht gegen den
widerstand von allen
das zeigt sich doch dass es andere
möglichkeiten gibt das land vor ort zu
machen muss dass vor allem die
bundesländer
hast du schon ein lied hat sich test
kapazitäten er versteht nicht versagt
haben man kann nicht alles immer aus dem
bunde abschieden gehört ganz ganz jungen
beim impfstoff einkauf und der schienen
anderen sachen auch über den ganzen
anderen rest wird nicht mehr sagen haben
kann die bundesländer sich nicht richtig
scheiße vielen dank peter dass du dir
die zeit genommen hast und du hast es
gerade gesagt konzentriert sich jetzt
dass sich selber und das soll so auch
tun wird ganz schnell wieder gesund und
ich soll live lieber peter während
durchgesprochen hat habe ich nachrichten
aufs handy bekommen von zuschauern die
sich aus dem aus dem vor dem kanzleramt
kennen und die mir gesagt haben bitte
sagt peter gute besserung wir vermissen
ihn und dass er schnell wieder zurück
ist und da geschrieben und ist
anschließend gehen dank peter alles gute